The joe rogan experience that
he has the consciousness.
Can you say on your end making sand
you'll get 15 years as an athlete
[inaudible] that two
cases came up positive.
Wow.
And Cooler and cooler and Cuba
at all those years. Two cases.
Two cases. He don't unless like I
don't know. I don't know. I don't know.
Like I don't have any clue who know and I,
which I tell them the on one guy was
in a weightlifter [inaudible] there.
Why he though that they called him
like a country motherfucker. Crazy.
He was crazy.
[inaudible] marijuana and the other
guy was positive for marijuana.
Yeah. If he don't get okay.
Kudelka Yo, what's the deal? Boy?
Testosterone. He was positive for
Telstra. How common is marijuana and Cuba?
I moved money.
You want to go up?
Si. Si, SI, Si. Si.
I know.
Alright,
so do not want to hand me that
if you start looking at it.
Sorry. Know soccer snuck
one. I move for the Cubans.
There's a lot of marijuana.
Okay. Me showed arena,
his niece noogaleek through. Nobody
wanted to hear, never saw a pop plan.
The Hawaii may show,
didn't know no sign and look at assessing
his nephew doesn't even know what it
is. No. God said [inaudible]
know who Johnny, I like this.
He didn't never even heard
people speak about it.
Beto Quando to us.
Um,
and this tree, when you go on the streets,
you know, I can't decide that. Okay.
Sit down at night. That's how I
look at some Becca go say, hey look,
come pick us up. But it goes, hey,
what's up? I see you on Percocet.
People know where the person saying
that people street, the people,
his marijuana illegal in Cuba.
He ain't got you get in
big trouble with Trevor,
Trevor and Joe. Yeah,
they, yeah. Well I see him.
God says he'll take it to a
hundred houses and mighty CD.
He not that real.
She Ain't,
God says he didn't go home with
just Cheetos and he'll get kids
[inaudible] [inaudible] I ordered
maybe now be, that's what she is.
[inaudible] the whole society and the
whole world's a little fucking crazy.
Right. But in and media and
media for his era there in Cuba,
and I can't take
[inaudible] [inaudible] and
I said, I don't know, but
they went together and I go,
yeah, it doesn't mean yours. That also
had kings out in your living room talking.
Nobody wanted them.
So I'll be able to get,
call it a hundred kids and take two at
each house and ask them if they know
marijuana is, they don't know what
it is. Wow. Yeah. MMM. Bridal.
But I'm wet Rosie for his now the system,
we live in
marijuana.
I bet on the marijuana.
But I'm not [inaudible] [inaudible] it's
not compared to what it's like here.
Hmm. I might want to just marijuana.
When Ozone Motley went to Cuba,
the band goes on Molly from La.
He told me he chopped. Oh yeah.
The cops on weight waiting. Cuba.
I would be so fucking scared. Yeah,
I wouldn't fuck it up.
You want to get locked up?
Oh,
what's that?
We'd ask him,
look how much time they give you the DS.
I'm in Tanya from 10 to 20 years.
But who she got it wrong for one joint.
Oh fuck that fool joint oof one uno.
Okay.